Finally, the last topic we'll cover in this class is AI ethics. Often,
scientists go about doing science without asking questions about the ethics of
the science they do. We are also engrossed in questions of funding and proposals
and papers. However, part of our job as scientists is to ask the question about
are we doing the right kind of things? There are a large number of
questions connected with the ethics of AI. We'll post a small number here today.
There are no easy answers to these questions. So I invite you to discuss these
questions on the forum? First, AI Ethics put into our economy and our society.
We have talked a lot in this course about designing AI agent that can act and
think and behave like humans. However, in the process,
we quite likely would replace some human jobs with robots. We have talked, for
example, of robots that can assemble a camera. Does this mean that humans who
assemble the cameras today will lose their jobs? Of course,
a counter argument is that new jobs might be created, for example, jobs for
designing robots. Nevertheless, there are hard issues, but ethical implications
of AI in terms of human economy and society. Second, much of the modern
development of AI is driven by defense applications all across the world.
We already have drones, for example. It is not far-fetched to imagine a future
where there are robot soldiers on the battlefield. What are the implications of
introducing robot soldiers? Should we build morality into these soldiers?
How do we do so? And if you are to build morality into robot,
what does it teach us about our own morality? A third and related question is,
that if it's hard building human characteristics like creativity and
morality into AI agents, at what point do these agents become like humans?
At what point do we start talking about civil rights for these machines
because they're indistinguishable from humans. The idea has been touched upon in
the popular culture a lot, but it is coming closer and closer to reality.
What are the criteria under which we'd consider machines to be equal to humans?